welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in Rick and Morty's hilarious
season four premiere just gave us the
show's closest ever look kinda at time
Medellin well kinda I guess knowing the
future and responding to it is a type of
time Medellin I just call making weekend
plans with friends time Medellin and
that's probably why I never have weekend
plans or friends anyway welcome to
explain it's our official Rick and Morty
after show that aims to trigger you with
Rick puns and adding the Splane suffix
to everything also to overanalyze the
crap out of each episode of Rick and
Morty to give you hot takes for reddit
up boats regardless of what your IQ is
we have invited Rick and Morty writer
and community I bet inspiration a bit
Ghaith on the show to chat about this
season four premiere in a bit so we have
a separate breakdown of all the
animation details and Easter eggs in
this episode coming out shortly after
this episode but first here is my quick
Rick's planation for the deeper agenda
of the season 4 episode 1 edge of temor
de Rick by Rick Pete its title nods to
the 2014 Tom Cruise film edge of
tomorrow lived I repeat a time loop
story set during a war against aliens in
which time resets every time Cruz dies
it's amazing it's kind of like Groundhog
Day meets Independence Day it's based on
the graphic novel all you need is kill I
believe that the deeper agenda of this
season 4 premiere what's to tread
dangerously close to the forbidden
fruits of Rick and Morty's since the
very beginning time travel or time
manipulation also reinforce the series
darker truth that no matter what Morty
does his relationship with Rick means he
is [ __ ] and this episode Maureen Rick
gather death crystals which allow one to
see into the future at all the various
ways that he can die for Morty one of
those alternate deaths seems to depict
him growing old with Jessica so he uses
the crystal as the kind of compass to
guide each step of his life along that
vector which ends up turning him into a
destructive monster the death time loop
structure of this episode is actually in
a B story Rick dies Morty refuses to
respawn him and so Rick's consciousness
instead responds in ultimate realities
most of them fascist the resets parallel
Tom Cruise's deaths and resets as well
as the loops that was on Groundhog Day
happy deathday the show Russian doll
it's a kind of a thing now now for some
Rick and Morty purists you could see
this is walking the line against the
series long-held rule against
time-travel Rick and Morty's the show
that expands horizontally across infant
dimensions not vertically forward or
backward upon a single timeline axis
series creators Justin roiland and Dan
Harmon have stated that time travel is
an overdone trope in sci-fi and they are
totally right even the MCU couldn't help
themselves now a time loop isn't the
same thing as time travel but I would
argue a character having foresight of
their destiny and planning out their
actions accordingly is the same kind of
narrative bubble as the ones of
time-travel stories a mere suggestion
that morty has a destiny that he can
steer toward or away from is an
acknowledgment of these same kind of
limits that time travel as a plot device
traps storytellers into we now know
Morty has a future well infinite futures
sure but in this episode his gaze
shifted from horizontally to vertically
with the same kind of obsession with his
future that heroes like Marty McFly
and Doctor Strange do and if you really
want to get English Lit major about this
morty an edge of tomorry
is really the Greek mythical character
Oedipus nope not because he wants to
kill Jerry and Mary Beth well maybe
that's true I guess we'll see but really
the story of Oedipus is a tragedy about
feet and foresight an Oracle tells
Oedipus that he is destined to kill his
father and marry his mother that
prophecy becomes an obsession for
Oedipus he flees his home in the people
he thinks are his parents but that fear
ironically led him directly to kill a
man who ended up being his real dad and
marry a woman who ended up being his
real mother now we've seen this kind of
tragedy over and over again in stories
there's the famous appointment in
Samarra fable in which a man's fear of
death leads him to flee ironically
exactly to the place he's fated to meet
death in these kind of stories the
knowledge of the future becomes its own
death curse so the moral is to live in
the present a warning rick states at the
beginning of this episode don't use them
people that spend their life avoiding
death are already dead but morty isn't
paying attention in that moment so he
ends up repeating the moral at the end
of the episode yes i got to learn how to
live in the moment a little more so you
actually learned something today
what is this full house I was living in
the moment all day and it kept getting
me killed by Nazis I think you have to
think ahead and live in the moment yeah
Rick's rebuttal reminds us that no
matter what Morty learns the world of
Rick and Morty is a cruel chaotic
godless one no harder earned life lesson
will save you unlike on full house in
which somehow each episode they escaped
death by the Olson clones
of Morty's infinite deaths the animators
snuck in there all of them were violent
and painful the one peaceful one Morty
strive toward with Jessica we learned in
the post-credits scene was actually a
lie future Jessica is simply a hospice
worker in this future Morty still dies
alone with his childhood crush at his
side but not out of any romantic love
for him it's a cruel joke lamps to the
cosmic slaughter and all that Egypt
Morty still doesn't open that Pandora's
box of time-travel stuff forever
untouched on Rick's shelf actually as we
learn in this episode in every dimension
in this episode it's time loop structure
diverges from edge of tomorrow and grand
all day and one key way this ends
unhappily for the hero Morty's foresight
doesn't free him it only trapped some in
a tunnel toward one of infinite horrible
fates but hey that's just my explanation
no other people have actually been in
the belly of the beast of the rick and
morty writers room i've invited former
rick and morty writer abbott gay through
chat about this episode right after a
message from our sponsors supporter
explain comes from a manscaped the best
in men's below-the-belt grooming
manscaped offers precision engineer
tools for your family jewels jingle
balls to the walls fellas listen up
untrimmed pubes are a thing of the past
it's time to gear up and get yourself
the gift of shaving this holiday season
I'm talking about the manscape perfect
package 2.0 snagging some skin while
shaving downstairs I'll turn any
reindeers nose red that's why manscaped
has redesigned the electric trimmer
their lawnmower 2.0 has proprietary
advanced skin save technology so this
trimmer won't Knick or snag your nuts
it's also waterproof so you can use it
in the shower this lawnmower 2.0 comes
inside their perfect package 2.0 which
makes for the perfect gift this holiday
season it's literally everything you
need to keep trimmed cut free and smell
a nice down there and don't use the same
trimmer on your faces you're using on
your balls manscape perfect package 2.0
also includes a crop preserver in the
crop Reviver to keep your balls from
sweaty and smelling and sticky and these
products smell good they're manly sit is
attractive and will help set the mood if
you know what I mean the perfect package
will also come with a pair of manscape
boxer briefs that will keep your junk
feeling fresh all day it's time to
upgrade those over use pair boxers to
manscape to high performance anti
chafing boxer briefs tis the season to
manscape so get yourself your dad your
brother friends
best gift of all a manscape perfect
package 2.0 get 20% off plus free
shipping with the code Rick's plane dat
manscape comm your balls will thank you
also guys have you ever been stuck in
the awkward experience of having to buy
cologne for yourself wandering the
aisles at a Macy's or Sephora I'm still
wearing that polo your grandma bought
you like for Christmas ago now seeing
your nostrils until everything smells
like burning smelling good is important
and that's why I love Hawthorne instead
of smelling a bunch of cents in a store
until they all smell the same Hawthorne
has you take a short quiz about your
lifestyle and preferences and then they
send you two cents one for work one for
play they offer this handy quiz
I loved it with a scale for Bo it goes
from no Bo
which is 100% of us right right to
painful Bo which is realistically 100%
of all of us they also have deodorant
shampoo and body wash the whole process
is easy and convenient best of all it's
totally risk-free with shipping and free
returns check out Hawthorne at Hawthorne
Co that's Hawthorne with an E and use my
promo code Ric to get 10% off your first
purchase that's H aw th o are in e dot
CO and use my code Ric to get 10% off
your purchase Hawthorne at CEO and we're
back now joining us to discuss the Rick
and Morty season four premiere is Rick
and Morty writer
Abed gates welcome to the show man
thanks for having me good how would he
do yes I also joining us is friend of
the show Rick and Morty superfan and
probably trapped in a time loop though
he doesn't know yet Tommy back to home
feel like I've been here before
well earlier episode we're talking about
how this episode has this time loop
plant structure that's based on live die
repeat in the Groundhog Day but it also
does something that Rick and Morty's
never done before and give Morty a
semblance of a fate of like a destiny
that he's either steering toward or
steering away from which is interesting
because a show has its famous no time
travel rule I don't think it necessarily
breaks that rule but it gets closer than
it's ever gotten before
Abed can you tell us like how that rule
came about and how it's like guided Rick
and Morty over the seasons I mean I
don't know the official reason but I
mean as a science fiction kind of nut I
will say that time travel is very like
an old hat it's just been done so many
times so to make a new to
make a sci-fi show and use it feels like
an old trope yeah that you're just sort
of rehashing old ideas yeah we were
talking before the show about how like
even the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
like okay I guess we'll do time travel
too as a way to explain things in it you
know it's it's like the writing the
alarm clock waking you up from a bad
dream when you're a kid writing short
fiction when you do like creative
writing you like I don't know how to end
this so you just go and I woke up and it
was my alarm clock and it was all a
dream and then your teacher tells you
not to do that and then you repeat
seventh grade I'm sure we've all had
that experience that's what time travel
you just you had to get held back and
you just justify it by saying that was
already the biggest kid so being the
biggest kid two years in a row not good
for your ego anyway I had that but with
underwear I mean like I think it's great
that Rick and Morty avoids like
time-travel applied like part of my soul
will break if they ever do that but I
love that they're willing to let
themselves do time loops and like
understanding of one's destiny and
whether or not you want to move toward
that or away from it are there other
like time-travel esque plots that we'd
probably be okay with Rick and Morty
doing if they wanted to explore that I
don't know I mean you know what I would
think would be very interesting is this
like maybe the like final 70th episode
yeah they maybe did a time travel Oh
finally they yeah and it almost did a
way to like alright now we're gonna do
the really cool thing that we shouldn't
have ever done right yeah we're gonna do
it so it seems like it would be a good
challenge to make that finally yeah I
feel like you guys haven't like smart
enough science fiction people in the
room that you could actually do a time
travel story that is both like logical
and makes sense but it's also like
entertaining and the self-awareness of
that show to me would be able to do they
do the best time travel episode because
they'd be able to comment on it
constantly about how they're doing it
differently or they're selling
themselves short or whatever but or
they're copping out by doing it so
there'd be a lot of I'm sure clever
time-travel references from many other
works of science fiction which is kind
of what is might one of my favorite
parts of the shows that draws us from
these other things it also kind of
identifies if they're [ __ ] or not so
we're also talking about lost before
this and how like lost had a version
they had a couple different versions of
time-travel which is probably not a
great idea but like one of the ones they
had was the whole like
slaughterhouse-five notion of like being
unstuck in time like your consciousness
is being displaced within the same body
throughout its own points in history
like I feel like Rick and Morty could do
a version of that like Rick's it's not
necessarily time-travel is just your
mind is swapping two different points in
your own timeline or life yeah that's a
very interesting way because
slaughterhouse-five is probably like the
best time travel yeah yeah so like that
would be great but I mean also who I
don't think any fans have read it it's
kind of dated you probably get away with
it actually yeah right that was
something that like I read in high
school it like blew my mind I'm like why
isn't every time travel stories
warehouse five it's the only one that
makes sense like you can time travel to
your death and it's just a purple void
and that's that's all that's there and
what a cool names slaughterhouse-five
it's like you think it's like a Jason
movie yeah yeah so this episode we saw
one of my favorite gags the red meeseeks
which is just a Kirkland brand receipt
of meeseeks that seems kind of lazy or
unenthusiastic smoking and we had Brian
Ridley on a past episode of the show and
he talked about that was apparently like
a pitch of his that has been brought up
in the room forever and ever we're kind
of speculating on what already exists so
it's crazy to see in the episode does
this set up a potential universe of
different colors of meeseeks the way
that like Yoshi's Island had like a red
yoshi blue yoshi a yellow Yoshi but
whatever colors be I would hope so
because that would be a fantastic
episode I kept wanting them to revisit
meeseeks yeah because I'm like it's such
a great idea that like it would just be
an amazing episode to like have a whole
planet but I think Justin's obsessed
with Nintendo so he gets where that
comes from
oh yeah his uh yeah Yoshi's Island I'd
like I wonder if that would be
fascinating just the way they had tales
of the Citadel to have like either
planet or a dimension of meeseeks that
they get like like dust it away or like
raptured suddenly from whatever they're
doing and now they have to be something
to be this genie in some other world and
they brought back and they're like older
and tired and traumatized and I'd love
to see like if a yellow meeseeks is like
two frenetic or something like that or
speaking another language or something
you afraid right yeah all the coward
yeah Greek doubt is back well you have
written on the past
interdimensional cable episodes and it
sounds like you were like a big
part of like all the pitches and the the
crazy one off ideas that were in there
were there any ideas that just you
didn't have time for they didn't make it
in the episode through the animation
process or the video uh oh well yeah oh
good guys there's a couple stories
during the first season
like I remember pitching something that
was like a homeless man who had a
steam-engine stomach that he had to fill
with coal and so he had to eat a lot of
coal and I mean I don't know if that was
a good idea I just remember dead like
looking at me and he kept questioning
the logic of it like so the guy's
homeless and what does he do like why
does he why does he figure out that
easycall like there's all these like he
was just like taking it apart bit by bit
and analyzing it I didn't have all day
it doesn't fit in the circle it stopped
right three there was like a technical
he wanted it badly yeah but he just
needed some kind of logic and I didn't
have it I just like the idea of him
having a Stevie Engine stomach it's
funny to me like it was like more just
trying to think of a visual funny thing
cuz I'm a big animation fanatic yeah so
I just like to see stuff that looks
funny sure you know so that was kind of
my inspiration working on it but there
was another thing I think it's probably
animated on like the special features
mm-hmm but there was one with butthole
ice cream where it was like like you go
to Yogurtland you know and it would just
be butts just shooting out like OOP and
like I think Ridley's like this is
disgusting I really was so Justin loved
it Justin was like that's going in the
episode I love it it's great oh my god
it's shooting out poop I love it and
then rides just like it makes me sick
you know like Ryan just put his foot so
I think it's animated but in black and
white so it's not it wasn't fully
finished yeah I got it like and then
well they might have done like this
stop-motion thing of it yeah like stupid
buddy or something yeah I mean I we've
all thought it like Nathan for use pilot
episode was just like the Pooh flavored
fro yeah yeah look every I can't not
think about it when I oh this is
interesting
well I don't know this is all the codes
here or not but so the hamster the you
know but yeah that whole thing
that was an episode idea oh it's all
another I said they should go to a
planet where that's those are running
around once again dad is like zero it
ain't on me and saying like so other
apartments in there you know what does
it look like inside
do they like see ya did an escape yeah
are the butts their homes or those like
their clothes or like mecha-suits or
their collars but see that's what's
crazy is the actual episode is that
conversation they're all asking
questions oh yeah and that's really
that's based on Dan asking any questions
he's so fascinated with the butts like
the answers of the but wants to get out
like yeah and I was just like I don't
know I didn't it's like that's it's in
my head I don't know where it came from
yeah I would say fascist Morty in this
episode seems like a nod to the fans
like cuz there's these lines where Rick
is asking him to say well just tell me
something that you like and he's like
mr. meeseeks and he says you will go
where I tell you to go and he's like
pining for this good old days of Rick
that probably don't exist and and then
not see more dee ins of dying in this
episode like do you think this comes
from a place of the writers feeling
exhausted of the fans trying to have too
much control over the direction of this
I'm sure that it that's a Dan yeah kind
of like feeling more than the other
writers like I mean I think he's he's
become I mean I don't like hang out with
him every day so don't know his state of
mind but I can imagine it's exhausting
you know to try to like to write a show
that tops what you've done but then
satisfy all these maniacs yeah who are
just never satisfied you know I mean
like you can't make something you can't
please everybody
sadly yeah and that show certainly does
please a lot of people yeah so I mean
he's doing fine yeah I'm doing right but
yeah like I it's most definitely based
on that yeah it's crazy how like they're
not just doing fine like they had this
long way between season 3 and season 4
and like I thought this season four
premiere was great like McMahon did such
a great job on the script all the
animation like it's packed with jokes
like it
it's one of my favorite top five
episodes of the series I saw that
animatic very early yeah and I seriously
thought it was gonna come out later yeah
but when it was the first episode I was
like oh they're just gonna hit the
ground running yeah yeah I had to watch
it twice because I was so overwhelmed I
was like I mean I loved it it was very
funny like you said the jokes I think
for me it was almost harder because
there were so many jokes that I was
having trouble following the storyline
because I was like eh either laughing or
trying to figure out why like oh how am
I not getting this and then so I thought
it was a difficult watch in a good way
like as a complex watch which is good it
did I think they didn't take their fans
for granted they were like you guys can
all jump right back on board this train
and go like well hit the ground and this
is a show that gets washed twice
it gets pause yeah people like go back
and like go back to in seconds and for
me it was like any time they were seeing
their futures and you just see these
shards and different futures I'm like oh
that's like an alien thing oh that's a
t2 thing and well I didn't even think of
that because I I was just there was so
much going on that I didn't even get to
focus on the other stole so there's just
so much and each one of those is like
its own separate episode that you could
just like imagine where you can already
play now it was probably all the
episodes they tossed aside right and you
know they didn't do yeah they all ended
up there that's good or what you know
this is actually what sometimes they do
is they gig sure every artist throws it
a die for different idea yeah you know
so only one kind of gets there a little
bit of something maybe it'd be like in
cocoa if they filled the underworld with
like other dead ideas of Pixar animated
cartoon just about that dead virgins in
underworld yeah yeah there's a SUP like
this episode that involved Hollow Rick
the the hologram version of Rick and he
he takes pride in his hologram existence
until he finally gets a corporeal body
from the feral flu and he becomes evil
and they they stab him with the wasp a
pincer and it goes in his eye and then
the wasp spawn and they burst his head
open Rick has this great line of I know
there's a lesson here but I'm not gonna
be the one to figure it out so I kinda I
feel like it's our job to figure out
what like what does it mean to have a
giant hollow Rick whose whole existence
is about taking pride in his like
marginalized existence but then turns
evil and has his head burst open by wasp
rakes I
I mean I guess Rick is a monster yeah
you know he's not a good person and deep
inside there's probably nothing
you don't need so it's like I always
don't I mean look I love the show right
it's a great shit's better than anything
on TV right now
and a biased but I do think rick is
really made yeah yeah you know he's like
he's just like poor Morty just could
never get a break yeah you know what I
mean so at that that's what I think I
think he's just an evil horrible person
yeah I think it's kind of also just I
mean like one of the things I do like
about Rick and Morty obviously a lot of
people do is that they do go cynical on
stuff like not cynical in a mean way but
they do you go they do kind of expose
the kind of like kind of dark nature of
people and like to me this was just kind
of a broad thing of like we all have
these friends we all know these people
to get behind these causes and they get
very passionate and then the opportunity
to go another way comes up that's like
either more selfishly lucrative
financially for them or pleasure-seeking
for them whether and then they
immediately turn their back on the cause
of their and it's like it just shows how
corruptible we all can be like the
second he got the thing that he was
fighting about having a quality to
instead he just got to be the thing that
has preceded me better which is having
an actual form a massive body he
immediately abandoned his his compassion
and his like empathy for people and
became a monster it was crazy how fast
that happen I think the speed the moment
he got a taste of like having flesh he
turned into evil guy but we see that
immediate is people were like all of a
sudden they make it they put a tweet out
and they'll start getting attacked by
people that were on their side before
whether it's a you know a political
thing or a cause and all of a sudden
they lash out and become angry and like
go against this we can read their entire
timeline before and it's all sensitivity
towards the subject and all of a sudden
they're super against it you know like I
feel like feminism is a great thing that
often happens people men claim to be
feminists and then some so I'm gonna tax
them for not being a feminist they start
going after women like yeah the true
feelings come out exactly yeah what was
what was the real motivation there's
usually something a little darker I
think that's what this was that's a very
good analogy that's better than mine
think so you actually got to work on the
show I'm working on the afternoon I
really think that really is about just
like our current state of just maniacs
on life well thank you so much for
joining us in this episode Abed this has
been so great to discuss the season four
premiere with you and thanks again to
Tommy's Bechtold
for joining us it was so great to chat
about this I really enjoyed this
conversation yeah yeah yeah like thanks
for having me I love talking about this
stuff it's very fun awesome awesome
well be sure to follow us on social
media at new rock stars and if you
haven't already subscribed to our Rick's
flame podcast feed wherever you get your
podcasts you'll get early access to
audio versions of everything you weren't
seeing right now or hearing right now if
you already are thank you for
subscribing coming soon will be our
in-depth breakdown of all like the
hidden animation jokes and Easter eggs
and all the cool little things the back
are the episode we're still doing those
and we're gonna be back next week with
our whole explanation of episode 2 and
thank you again for joining us and let's
close out with uh what we thought was a
great joke this episode but first
something silly what do you mean but
first I already said up next you always
do those always do [ __ ] don't gasoline
gas lighting does it exist you made it
up because you're in cream
[Music]